,
JAKE.
>> SELINA WANG IN BEIJING FOR
US, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TURNING NOW TO OUR WORLD LEAD
WHERE WOMEN IN AFGHANISTAN ARE
PROTESTING AGAINST THE
TALIBAN'S LATEST CRACKDOWN ON
THE RIGHTS AND FREEDOMS.
THE TALIBAN THIS WEEK BANNED
ALL FEMALE STUDENTS FROM
RECEIVING COLLEGE EDUCATIONS, A
DEVASTATING MOVE.
SOME FEAR IT WILL ULTIMATELY BE
EXTENDED FOR GIRLS BELOW THE
SIXTH GRADE WHEN IT COMES TO
THEIR EDUCATION.
CNN'S CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR
REPORTS ON YET ANOTHER SETBACK
FOR AFGHAN WOMEN AND GIRLS
SINCE THE U.S. LEFT.
>> ANOTHER WEEK, ANOTHER
DRAMATIC REVERSAL OF WOMEN'S
RIGHTS IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE TALIBAN'S NEW --
SUSPENDING UNIVERSITY EDUCATION
FOR FEMALES IS A MAJOR SETBACK
FOR WOMEN THERE AND THE
MINISTRY OF EDUCATION SAID, THE
RULE WILL TAKE IMMEDIATE
EFFECT.
>> THERE IS NO LIFE FOR WOMEN
IN AFGHANISTAN ANYMORE
SENSITIVE CLOSE ALL THE ROUTES
TOWARDS SUCCESS FOR WOMEN.
WHEN THE DOORS OF SCHOOLS AND
UNIVERSITIES ARE CLOSED FOR THE
WOMEN WHO ARE HALF THE SOCIETY,
IT MEANS THE PROCESS OF HUMAN
EVOLUTION AND DEVELOPMENT IS
PARALYZED.
>> YOUNG WOMEN, SHOWING UP TO
CLASS IN UNIVERSITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE NOW BEING TOLD
TO GO BACK HOME.
EVEN WORSE, FEARS THE BAN COULD
EXTEND TO ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS.
THE PRINCIPLES OF THREE COUPLE
WORLD SCHOOLS TELL CNN, THE
TALIBAN HAVE WRITTEN TO THEM,
TELLING THEM TO SHUT DOWN.
STUDENTS QUICKLY SHOWED THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE NEW LAW, BOTH
MEN AND WOMEN INCLUDING AT NINE
TO HEART UNIVERSITY IN THE CITY
OF JALALABAD.
ACCORDING TO REUTERS, MALE
MEDICAL STUDENTS THERE EVEN
WALKED OUT OF THEIR FINAL EXAMS
TO SUPPORT THEIR FEMALE
CLASSMATES.
>> THEY CAN'T GO TO SCHOOL.
WHY?
THEY CANNOT WORK.
SOMEBODY, SOMEBODY PLEASE TELL
ME.
WHY?
>> THIS NEW POLICY IS THE
LATEST ANNOUNCEMENT ON WHAT
MANY ARE CALLING THE SYSTEMATIC
EXPULSION OF AFGHAN WOMEN FROM
ALL ASPECTS OF PUBLIC LIFE.
WHEN I TRAVELED TO KABUL THIS
SPRING, I CONFRONTED A TALIBAN
OFFICIAL, THE VERY DAY THEY
DEMANDED THAT ALL WOMEN IN WORK,
EVEN ON TELEVISION, HAD TO BE
MASKED.
>> AFGHAN WOMEN ARE AFRAID THAT
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF YOUR
EFFORTS TO ERASE THEM FROM THE
WORK SPACE.
>> BACK THEN, THE MOST SENIOR
TALIBAN GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL,
SIRAJUDDIN COUNTY, TOLD ME THAT
HE WOULD SAFEGUARD THE RIGHTS
OF AFGHAN WOMEN, INCLUDING THE
RIGHT TO AN EDUCATION.
>> THERE IS NO ONE WHO OPPOSES
EDUCATION FOR WOMEN.
AND ALREADY, GIRLS ARE ALLOWED
TO GO TO SCHOOL UP TO GRADE
SIX.
BUT WHAT I'M SAYING TO YOU IS
THAT VERY SOON, YOU WILL HEAR
VERY GOOD NEWS ABOUT THIS ISSUE,
GOD WILLING.
THAT PROMISE NEVER MATERIALIZED
AND THIS WEEK, WOMEN AND GIRLS
RIGHTS HAVE TAKEN A MAJOR STEP
BACKWARDS.
IN FACT, OFFICIALS WHO PLEDGED
THEY WOULD BE DIFFERENT THAN
TALIBAN ONE POINT OH ARE NOW
ACCELERATING THEIR MARCH BACK
TO THAT SAME HARSH VERSION.
THIS IS MY INTERVIEW WITH THE
TALIBAN OFFICIAL BACK IN 1996.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW
WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO DO ABOUT
THE WOMEN ISSUE, WHAT ABOUT
WOMEN'S EDUCATION GIRLS,
EDUCATION, WOMEN WORKING,
WIDOWS WHO HAVE NO OTHER WAY TO
SUPPORT THEMSELVES?
>> I KNOW THAT ESPECIALLY IN
WESTERN NEWS MEDIA, IT'S THE
PROPAGANDA AGAINST THAT WE ARE
AGAINST WOMEN IN EDUCATION,
WHICH IS NOT RIGHT.
THAT IS NOT CORRECT.
>> THE GIRLS CAN'T GO TO
SCHOOL.
WE'VE BEEN TO SCHOOLS HERE,
THEY ARE ALL CLOSED.
>> SINCE THE TALIBAN CAME BACK
TO POWER LAST YEAR, WOMEN HAVE
BEEN BANNED FROM MOST
WORKPLACES FROM POLITICS, AND
FROM ENTERING PUBLIC PARKS,
PUBLIC BARS.
THE EVEN NOW REQUIRE EMIL
GUARDIAN FOR LONG DISTANCE
TRAVEL.
MORE PRAGMATIC TALIBAN SOURCES
TELL CNN, THESE BANDS COME
STRAIGHT FROM THE TALIBAN'S
SO-CALLED SUPREME LEADER, EMIR
OF DATA, AND HIS KITCHEN
CABINET BASED IN KANDAHAR.
THEY FORM THE CORE OF THE
HARD-LINE RELIGIOUS LEADERSHIP.
THE UNITED NATIONS SAYS, IT'S
OUTRAGE AND IS CALLING ON THE
TALIBAN TO REVERSE THE DECISION.
THE UNITED STATES SAID THAT IT
WOULD FURTHER ALIENATE THE
TALIBAN FROM THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY AND DENY THEM THE
LEGITIMACY AND RECOGNITION THEY
CRAVE.
IN THE LAST TWO DECADES SINCE
THE TALIBAN WAS FIRST DRIVEN
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN, MANY URBAN
WOMEN WERE EXCELLING IN SCHOOL
AND IN THE WORKFORCE,
CONTRIBUTING TO THE COUNTRY'S
ECONOMY, SOCIETY, AND CULTURE.
NOW, THAT HALF THE POPULATION
IS BEING ERASED FROM PUBLIC
VIEW AND PUBLIC WORKS, THIS
COUNTRY IS FALLING EVER FASTER,
EVER DEEPER INTO EXTREME
POVERTY AND HUNGER.
AS ANOTHER BLE